the measure of a good life i think is to
feel that you have made a contribution
to the world or to your country or to
your society that you've been a
constructive and productive human being
during the time you have here on this
earth it's to feel that you have good
friends and strong family ties that are
important friends and family are are
extremely important not only are they
uplifting in terms of your own life but
they sort of reaffirm the value of life
itself they reaffirm this this notion
that you're not an individual you're
part of a society where family and
friends are important and deep family
values I think are extremely important
and deep values of loyalty to your
friends are extremely important I think
also enjoying respect the respect of
other people were they where they
respect you as a human being for your
integrity for your candor for your
willingness to help them in tough times
being a fair-weather friend does not
really constitute my judgment much of a
friendship it's being there not just in
the good times but when times are tough
being there for others and it's and it's
also demonstrating good values in the
way you deal with other people that you
have respect for others that you care
about them that you are willing to work
with other people and one of the things
I look at and others is are they as
respectful of the guy who opens the door
in your apartment or the taxi driver or
the waiter at a restaurant as they are
of their boss of someone who can control
whether they have a job
or whether they get promoted or what
salary they get I think you have to have
respect for people across the board if
you are disrespectful people because you
don't think they can do anything for you
but highly respect full of people who
you need in order to advance in your
career you're really living a sort of
bifurcated life and I watch people and
how they deal with others and I try on
my own to to recognize that that dealing
with others and recognizing they have
they want respect just as you do is an
important part of a ones at least my
value system
hey